and the world
four years
in itself but too much
ronsin
[Music]
so at first I was not a pilot of
anything I have always been
passionate about birds but about
thirty years ago I read a
article on the disappearance of a species
in the wild lohan n white-fronted i
thought to myself if i manage to guide
new generation customs n white-fronted
n on a new route i will be
able to start reintroducing them
in the wild because  that they had
been exterminated by the abuses of hunting
where they spend the winter around the
black sea and the caspian sea they
reproduce and in scandinavia and spend
the winter around the black sea
and we did it  in 1999 with my
wife with 30.3 wang who followed us
on a long journey from northern
sweden to a wintering site on the
banks of the rhine in germany where the birds
memorize this new journey with us and
from spring  following after a
wintering in germany they s
returned alone to the reserve they
had left so it had worked well oh
how do you manage to fly with
birds with a microlight you have to be able to
raise the young birds put the
eggs in an incubator to see couples
who are  reproduce here the young are raised
as their parents would do it
is the phenomenon of impregnation turn
imprint because from birth to
leaving the egg we are in the presence
of the birds from that moment they
consider us as the parent so
every year I raise birds as
if I were their parents and they
naturally follow me in flight as if
I were their part years we spend a lot
of time in nature with them we sleep
with them I bathe here in this
mare with its little voices when they
are very young and they have to get used to the
sound of my voice the goslings
recognize the facial features very very well
you get used to the noise
of the engine very early and to the silhouette  from
the eu to the east I got certificates
to be able to breed her birds it's
protected species anyone ca
n't breed them and to be able to
fly with her too you need
special certificates
[Music]
oh
no
[Music]
I fly almost every day with
birds when the weather allows it
obviously
the wind must not be too strong
it must not rain too much what
if they need to fly to stay
muscular because  that if I abandon them
for a few weeks, well, you have to
start all over again afterwards because you need
the key airbus when you have
low pets you walk your dog in the
morning in the evening so that they spend
energy and at the  birds it's
the same so they enjoy flying
with me but since I have so much
experience I have thousands of hours
of flying with birds there are never any
accidents I could possibly
lose birds if I don't  did not know
observed my birds could know  r when
a bird is tired and because
these species are gregarious there
is a whole range of vocalizations that it
expresses and I learned to recognize
all these sounds which also allows me to
anticipate what is going to happen  in
flight I would say to simplify things
that it is not me who teaches these
birds to fly with me it is these
birds for 27 years that I have been flying with
them who have taught me how to
fly well with my seasons to follow me
flight  it's not me who follows them but
lifting I leave them in front of the
machine to be able to control them better
and I observe them but it follows all
the movements of the machine it is placed
in front or behind or on the side but
it is the machine  that they follow and the
person who pilots the machine if we are
two microlights flew together the other pilot
also raised these birds they
know him very well and this lot the
technique of piloting we can exchange
the birds in flight
the  species conservation flights
s it does not concern for the moment
a species of white fronted lane laws and
parallel to that and well I propose
flights with the tourists to be able to
collect money to finance my
various projects it is flights which
lasts only 35 to 40  minutes but during a
meager migration it's really a long
trip that we do over thousands of
kilometers I fly four hours in
general it's very difficult because
I fly with a lot of birds
groups that are about thirty  of birds you have to
be very very concentrated flying
with a passenger it's more a leisure flight
we have a lot of fun flying
and we have people from all over the world
who come to fly with the birds in
the same morning I have  sometimes five or six
different nationalities sometimes there are
disabled people who have difficulty
moving in their bodies and who fly
like birds with birds and
then there are never two alike flights
the birds are different according to
the  aerology according to the palate the
temperament of the passenger it is a duty
for me to communicate to the public
the need to have to protect these
birds since I have been flying I have
always flown only with birds if I have
no  birds in flight i miss